[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue comme
chaque jour 30 minutes de sujets et de
débatteur pour confronter leurs opinions
bonsoir jérôme sainte marie
vous êtes politologues et sondeurs vous
avez créé votre propre institut pôle
inbox et vous est aussi l'auteur de
plusieurs livres dont le dernier bloc
contre bloc la dynamique du maquereau
nisme a été publié aux éditions du sel
nous avons aussi le plaisir d'avoir sur
ce plateau mathieu sous pierre bonsoir
matière vous êtes expert associé à la
fondation jean jaurès
vous avez votre propre activité de
conseil vous avez collaboré aux cabines
est d'au moins deux ministres de femmes
myriam el khomri elisabeth bornes ce
n'est pas au cabinet d'elisa bleus
étaient pas au cabinet pour la
conseiller non accompagné quelques temps
de l'ombre discret mais officiel très
bien
pardon si vous le voulez bien pour
commencer d'un projet de loi qui va
arriver au conseil des ministres mi
avril on ne connaît pas encore
parfaitement les contours
mais il est important c'est un projet de
réforme de la justice l'objectif du
garde des sceaux qui conduit ce projet
eric dupond moretti est de rapprocher
donc les français de la justice
il ya peut-être du travail surtout
peut-être on va en discuter
depuis l'annnonce du jugement de nicolas
sarkozy le garde des sceaux était
justement interrogé sur ce sujet ce
matin sur france inter
et voilà le commentaire qu'il faisait ou
qu'il ne faisait pas parce que ce
n'était pas facile à lui compte tenu de
son poste de la condamnation de l'ancien
président de la république ça pose le
problème de la défiance que l'on peut
avoir à l'encontre de la justice et
c'est une défiance par non
indépendamment de cette affaire eu du
président sarkozy qu exprime également
les français par voie de sondage vous a
pas échappé que dans la dernière étude
cevipof
moins d'un français sur dix ne pas avoir
confiance dans la justice et mon projet
de loin nous en parlerons a justement
pour but et pour seul but pour restaurer
la confiance que les français doivent
avoir dans la justice parce que de quoi
parle-t-on
on parle de pacte social ici
alors eric dupond moretti a parlé de
sondages donc on se tourne naturellement
vers vous jérôme est ce que vous pensez
même s'il ya pas eu d' enquêtes
d'opinion que le jugement
habituellement considéré comme sévère on
va dire du tribunal correctionnel de
paris à l'encontre de l'ancien président
de la république peut accentuer cette
défiance
oui alors monsieur dupont moretti a fait
une partie de mon travail il a cité
effectivement ce sondage du celi pop ce
sondage opinionway pour être précis et
par rapport à ma réaction quand j'ai
entendu le jugement d'hier a été que
c'était plus maintenant quand il va
juste vendre ce genre et notamment celui
ci ça n'allait pas engendré une défiance
accrue des français à l'égard du
politique sur le thème tous pourris mais
cette fois ci c'est accroître la
défiance des français
effectivement à l'égard de la justice
par un effet de contraste qu'elles
soient les critiques que font les
français depuis des années à l'égard de
la justice d'une part c'est bien entendu
sa distance à lenteur essentiellement et
puis une autre critique qui portait
notamment à droite mais pas seulement
qui est nourrie aussi par les propos des
syndicats de police qui est de dire
c'est une justice qui n'accompagne pas
suffisamment le travail difficile des
policiers qui est trop laxiste en
quelque sorte avec la violence de rue ce
genre de choses évidemment comme une
institution est critiquée et qu'en plus
elle prend une décision qui paraît
contestable c'est très mauvais en
quelque sorte on va dire elle est très à
l'aise pour juger sévèrement non pas un
puissant mais quelqu'un qui l'a été mais
qui de fait est tombé du cheval qui veut
dire qu'il n'est plus au pouvoir alors
même qu'elle est n'est pas très efficace
sur les tâches sur lesquels on l'attend
en quelque sorte elle se met deux choses
qui la regardent pas alors que ne
remplit pas ses fonctions sur là où elle
est nécessaire
donc je pense qu'effectivement le
jugement d'hier va avoir des
conséquences
il est indéniable qu'une bonne partie de
l'opinion s'en réjouit sur les réseaux
sociaux je vois ça c'est la danse du
scalp dans les milieux de gauche qui est
plein de gens qui sont très contents
sarkozy mord la poussière etc
c'est pas très brillant mais c'est là ça
existe et puis pareil mais par ailleurs
vous avez aujourd'hui plusieurs
électorat qui sont très remontés contre
la justice
avant même cette affaire l'électorat de
jean luc mélenchon l'électorat de marine
le pen
l'électorat de françois fillon ça fait
du monde même majoritaire des gens qui
ont l'impression que la justice n'a pas
été tout à fait équitable à leur égard
et du coup il ya une large audience pour
critiquer la décision prise hier alors
vous citiez un certain nombre de
critiques qui sont veut porter à l'égard
de la justice c'est justement l'objectif
de cette réforme que d'essayer
d'améliorer les choses je donne deux
exemples
parliez de la longueur de la lenteur
excessive de la justice eric
dupond-moretti voudraient encadrer la
les enquêtes préliminaires afin qu'elle
ne dure pas trop longtemps afin aussi
d'éviter peut-être ça a été un des
éléments pointés du doigt dans l'anc est
du parc national financiers dans la
sphère sarkozy de d'attendre pendant des
années jusqu'à ce qu' entre guillemets
on trouve quelque chose et puis il ya un
autre point aussi c'est la suppression
de la réduction automatique des peines
assez peut-être pour répondre à aux
reproches de laxisme entre guillemets
portées par certains syndicats de
policiers
mathieu sous caire parce qu'à vous
travaillez avec un projet de loi on peut
rétablir cette confiance qui qui s'est
beaucoup dégradée en tout cas pour
certains français vis-à-vis de la
justice alors un élément là dessus je
suis d'accord avec beaucoup des choses
caddy cadet john mensah pardon je vous
pose une autre question est ce que ça
vous a frappé ou choquer vous ce verdict
est ce que vous vous dites quand même il
a il a pris cher alors ça m'a surpris et
contrairement à l'or ça m'a surpris sans
être un expert en affaires judiciaires
donc en fait mon avis était celui de
quelqu'un qui s'attablent au café du
commerce et rien de plus mais j'étais en
ce moment sur n'a pas droit et et je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ce que dit jérôme
là dessus je ne crois que je crois que
personne à gauche ne sait pour de vrai
réjouit de voir que pour la première
fois sous la vème république un
président de la république était
condamné à la prison ferme
je pense que n'importe quel démocrate
vie cette affaire très mal et
s'inquiètent quand même des conséquences
que cela peut avoir sur l'opinion
publique
à un an de la présidentielle car je
pense que vous avez raison jérôme ça va
accroître la défiance qu'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens peuvent
nourrir vis-à-vis de l'institution
judiciaire
mais je crains quand même que ça ne
contribue encore à alimenter la défiance
qui existent vis-à-vis de la classe
politique et ça je pense que c'est que
c'est très rude d'autant plus que
nicolas sarkozy a été condamné dans
cette affaire mais qui en a d'autres aux
basques si je puis me permettre
et il revient devant le devant les
tribunaux dans quinze jours encore il
pourrait être de nouveau condamné et
tout ça fera boule de neige
et tout ça tout ça est inquiétant bon
ensuite on a effectivement une opinion
qui est assez schizophrène par rapport à
la justice encore une fois la justice
la cote de confiance de la justice est
assez basse
mais elle est relativement constante on
ne peut pas dire que le lien de
confiance s'est dégradée en moyenne
durée on est on est on est à peu près
toujours entre 40 et 50% et là on est à
48 c'est pas si pire
oserais je dire c'est pas si pire en
moyenne durée on est très au dessus par
exemple de la confiance quant à une fois
la confiance dont sont crédités les
politiques ou les journalistes syndrome
les syndicats on est au dessus de la
confiance que les français font aux
grandes entreprises par exemple aux
banques
vous voyez ce n'est pas c'est pas si
pire pour la justice mais effectivement
ça questionne non seulement il ya une
confiance limitée dans la justice mais
il ya globalement le sentiment 62 % des
français pensent que la justice
fonctionne mal que l'institution
fonctionne mal et la moitié des français
pensent que les magistrats eux-mêmes ne
sont pas neutres et impartiaux dans les
jugements qu'ils rendent et ça
effectivement vis-à-vis de l'institution
comme vis-à-vis des hommes et des femmes
qui l'incarné qui la font fonctionner la
défiance est élevé et est allé
problématique on est schizophrène dans
le rapport que la justice entretien avec
le pouvoir politique avec le pouvoir
exécutif
pendant très longtemps le procès était
un procès en instrumentalisation la
justice était aux ordres et désormais on
lui reproche non seulement de ne plus
être aux ordres mais de faire un excès
de zèle hexagonaux arrangé avec un avec
une bande noire alors une loi qui par
ailleurs arrive en fin de quinquennat
j'ai des doutes
je pense que enfin il eût été sans doute
préférable qu encore une fois une
réforme interviennent plus tôt le hiatus
vient de quelque chose d'assez évident
et et on demande à la justice
de plus en plus de choses comme
d'ailleurs à tous nos services publics
il ya une demande de justice une demande
d'intervention nisme public en matière
de justice
beaucoup plus importante qu'avant et en
même temps des moyens qui n'ont pas
suivi et je mexplique parce que ça
répond au procès en laxisme qu'on fait à
la justice la justice n'a jamais autant
condamner qu'aujourd'hui le nombre de
condamnations prononcées chaque année
augmente constamment
le nombre de condamnations prononcées au
cours des quinze dernières années a
augmenté de 17 % le nombre de
condamnations et au delà même du nombre
de condamnations
la dureté des peines elle même a
augmenté et on a aujourd'hui en fait en
termes de condamnation à de la prison
ferme
un stock record je disais ça dans un
rapport du ministère de justice lui-même
de 4,85 milanais de condamnation on a
aujourd'hui
des gens qui sont enfermés dans nos
prisons on était à 70 milles il ya
quelques mois on est à 60 mille postes
qu vide et on a 70 mille détenus en
france et la totalité des peines dont
ils sont chargés
ça fait 85 mille années chiffre record
dans l'histoire judiciaire française
donc on ne peut pas dire que la justice
est laxiste
en revanche oui c'est vrai elle est
lente alors encore une fois elle n'est
pas plus lente que celle de nos voisins
elle est lente parce qu'elle est engorgé
par ce qu'on lui demande beaucoup sans
l'avoir encore une fois doté à échelle à
mesure c'est pas le tout pour faire une
polémique mais juste comme il est je
vous donne un autre sondage parce que
parce qu'il m'a vu il m'a frappé dans un
sondage ifop de 2019
moins d'un français sur deux 47%
considèrerait les juges comme neutres et
impartiaux dans leur jugement et c'était
dix points de moins qu'en 2011 aux usa
parce que loi pour le coup c'était pas
stable oui mais ça n'est pas de la
défiance c'est vrai c'était le jugement
sur la neutralité
je vous donne le point de vue de nos
internautes qui considère à 76% que le
projet d'eric dupond moretti ne pourra
pas restaurer la confiance donc un
certain scepticisme voire même un
scepticisme certain alors teddy sur
youtube naudy déjà le personnage de
dupond moretti ne m'inspire aucune
confiance alors sa réforme
nicole sur lefigaro.fr considère qu'on
n'aura pas une meilleure opinion de la
justice avec ce projet de loi
et puis sur lefigaro.fr toujours une
autre temps que ceux qui doivent être
sanctionnés ne le sont pas je n'aurai
pas confiance
anonyme sur lefigaro.fr il faut surtout
construire plus de prisons
bref
là encore une fois nos internautes sont
assez critiques pour restaurer la
justice nous dit micheline sur youtube
il faut qu'elle soit vraiment
indépendante juste et impartiale il faut
rendre ce système irréprochable et
neutre et de leur côté les citoyens
doivent respecter les décisions de
justice c'est vrai même si c'est un
programme ambitieux alors je reviens un
instant à la sphère au jugement de
nicolas sarkozy sur l' affaire dite des
écoutes mais aussi sur le projet d'eric
dupond moretti l'un des reproches qui a
été fait à l'instruction
c'est que les écoutes les lis pas dans
les contacts téléphoniques entre nicolas
sarkozy et son avocat ont été écoutés
par la justice il faudra donc peut-être
renforcer ce cette règle du secret pour
la défense en tout cas c'est ce que veut
faire eric dupond moretti
parce qu'il n'existe plus j'ai assisté
depuis trente ans un délitement du
secret professionnel
ce secret n'a pas pour vocation de
protéger les avocats il faut être clair
là-dessus un avocat n'est pas au dessus
des
cette barre il encore on n'a pas de
dents quête d'opinion mais est-ce que
vous pensez que les français sont
choqués qu'on ait pu écouter des
conversations entre nicolas sarkozy et
son avocat alors je suis pas sûr parce
que les pratiques de la machine
judiciaire la plupart des français ne
les connaissent pas moi je trouve ça
personnellement extrêmement choquant si
vous voulez mais pas des gens
connaissent pas mais il faut bien voir
que l'opinion est abreuvé par des
différentes sources idéologiques qui
remonte à des siècles parfois et qui
nourrissent quand même une défiance que
je trouve scène à l'égard de la justice
dira que les libéraux tout on parle
toujours des lumières voltaire pour un
oui pour un non et c'est tous ces gens
là ont passé leur temps à critiquer
l'appareil judiciaire de l'époque et à
faire une d avoir des ennuis avec lui
parfois et à faire une distinction
naturelle entre la justice qui est un
concept et l'appareil judiciaire qui est
une réalité sociale très particulière et
qui se comporte pas toujours très bien
selon les époques et donc vous avez
effectivement une critique libéral de la
justice
le libéralisme politique à travers toute
l'europe et en france également a
toujours été très attentive à préserver
les droits de l'accusé et donc à
contrôler le comment dirais-je à limiter
en quelque sorte les droits du procureur
du parquet etc
vous avez également une critique que
tout à fait différente une critique
marxiste qui est aussi riguet l'opinion
à gauche pendant très longtemps que la
dénonciation d'une justice de classe
c'était quand même les années 70 ils s
étaient tous là et alors viens une
période enchanté si on va se dire pour
la justice par rapport à la politique ça
a été un peu sur le modèle de l'italie
sur notre pays
ça a été et puis sur le modèle aussi des
comédies afin d'aider dramatique des
films dramatiques américain cette idée
qu'il y avait deux pouvoirs formidable
la justice et les médias qui allait
rétablir en quelque sorte défendre le
peuple rétablir la vérité c'est le
watergate c'est tout ce qu'on veut et et
nous avons alors elle les écoute des
avocats et vous allez encore vous aviez
plein de films comme ça et je n'ai sa
formation d'opinion 70 plein de films
ont un design et juge le petit juge
héroïque qui rétablit la probité
publique
ça c'était vrai les années 80 90 etc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout
le cas
et pour les avocats effectivement
maintenant vous avez une opinion qui est
beaucoup plus dubitative
sans parler de beaucoup d'ailleurs
d'électeurs de droite qui ont
l'impression quand même que l'issue de
la campagne de 2017 a été largement
influencés par le comportement du
parquet national financiers et donc la
l'égard de françois fillon et de
françois fillon
et je crois qu'effectivement maintenant
il ya il ya une forme de défiance qui
s'est instauré alors je vous réponds pas
tellement pour une raison toute simple
c'est que je suis pas sûr que les gens
soient très sensible à cette question
précise l'avocat faut bien voir que les
avocats ont pas très bonne presse comme
d'ailleurs le ministre dupont moretti
le garde des sceaux beaucoup de français
ont souvent l'impression que le garde
l'avocat a en quelque sorte du côté de
l'accusé voire même ils confondent
parfois l'avocat et la puiser en quelque
sorte
donc c'est vrai que la plupart des
affaires c'est difficile d'être avocat
est d'ailleurs le fait d'avoir choisi un
avocat pour être garde des sceaux n'est
pas forcément un choix politiquement
très facile puisque d'enfants il ya
demande une justice plus ferme
choisir un avocat a pu décevoir pas mal
de monde le jeu nuance ce que dit jérôme
là dessus sauf erreur de ma part je ne
sais plus si tu es ma source
au moment où l' affaire avait éclaté
donc il y a déjà quelques années une en
une enquête d'opinion avait permis
d'établir que les français étaient à
l'époque davantage choquée par
précisément cette affaire de fadettes et
le contrôle de les écoutes téléphoniques
que par la mise en cause de nicolas
sarkozy elle même ce qui était peut-être
étonnant mais donc les français
n'étaient pas insensibles à cette
affaire et aujourd'hui je note quand
même que dans les commentaires qui sont
faits y compris compris de ceux qui
demandaient que justice parce que
nicolas sarkozy soit bien traité comme
un justiciable comme un autre
globalement tout le monde a considéré
tout de même que la pratique des
magistrats du pnf était à tout le moins
douteuse personne n'a compris qu'on
puisse mettre sur écoute tout de même un
avocat
donc je crois que là-dessus il ya il ya
quand même une forme d'une forme de
consensus
je voudrais terminer en visitant
casamayor qu'était un magistrat qui
était aussi un auteur de livres c'est
une citation d'ailleurs que eric
dupond-moretti adore mais moi aussi et
il dit le drame de la justice c'est que
l'on a donné à une administration le nom
d'une vertu et puis
quelques mots aussi de nos internautes
qui mérite toujours d'être cités il ya
des questions aussi sur le parquet
xavier sur lefigaro.fr nous dit qu'il
devrait être indépendant et que le pnf
devrait être dissous d'urgence et les
juges élus ce serait effectivement une
réforme à l'américaine mais ça cher
xavier ça n'est pas dans le projet de
loi d'eric dupond-moretti et puis aussi
cette remarque de nicole 06 qui trouvent
que jour où les juges du siège du
parquet seront réellement pénaliser
quand ils feront des fautes lourdes
l'opinion changera peut-être
il est vrai que c'est assez
spectaculaire de voir que le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature donne suite
à un nombre très très minime des
plaintes qui sont présentés par les
justiciables vis-à-vis de l'institution
on change de sujet mais on reste dans
les sondages celui là va sans doute
faire plaisir à emmanuel macron il a été
réalisé par l'ifop pour nos confrères de
sud radio et de paris match et alors
c'est intéressant parce que pour tout
vous dire moi j'étais vraiment surpris
par les acheteurs ce sondage ça fait des
jours notamment ça a fait l'objet d'une
une de libération en fin de semaine
dernière que l'on nous répète que les
électeurs de gauche sont très déçus par
emmanuel macron parce que la ligne
suivie et est trop à droite que
d'ailleurs ça pourrait les amener à
éventuellement s'abstenir et à favoriser
marine le pen
et puis patatras ce sondage ne dit
absolument pas ça il nous apprend que
quarante deux pour cent des électeurs de
gauche c'est-à-dire un nombre supérieur
à ceux qui répondent le contraire
quarante deux pour cent des électeurs de
gauche approuvent l'action des manuels
macron contre 35% qui ne l'approuvent
pas alors dans la série des bonnes
nouvelles il ya aussi les jeunes qui
apparemment
exprimée en sont satisfaits de l'action
du président de la république 62 %
approuvent c'est peut-être l'effet mcfly
carlito vous savez si ces influenceurs
acquis emmanuel macron proposé de faire
une vidéo
tout ça fait que le président de la
république se porte assez bien regarder
son taux de satisfaction par rapport à
celui de ses deux prédécesseurs il
s'élève à 41 % pour emmanuel macron à la
même époque de son mandat nicolas
sarkozy n'était qu'à 31 % et françois
hollande à 22%
d'où cette question un peu provocatrice
c'est gagné pour 2022
mapfre iker alors non il ya d'ailleurs
pas de contradiction entre les chiffres
que vous énoncez qui m'ont surpris
moi-même néanmoins et ce qui se
racontait dans libé le week-end dernier
s'est rappelé qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'intention de vote
il s'agit encore une fois de
satisfaction et on parle par ailleurs de
public qui sont susceptibles de
s'abstenir qu'il s'agit qu'il s'agisse
des jeunes pardon ou des simples ou des
sympathisants de gauche
je ne suis pas sûr que et il il
manifeste un zèle appuyé au moment
d'aller voter dans un an vous qui êtes
jeunes et de gauche vous pensez qu ils
peuvent s'abstenir même s'il s'en
satisfait alors je ne comprend pas la
polémique qu'a suscitée par exemple la
une de libération ce week-end car c'est
effectivement quelque chose qu'on entend
de plus en plus c'est à dire que même si
emmanuel macron se maintient à un niveau
de popularité tout à fait honorable tout
à fait honorable l'anti macro nisme
lentilles macro nice met aujourd'hui
très puissant et en gros à part ceux qui
encore aujourd'hui se satisfont à peu
près de la politique qu'il mène je
dirais que tous les autres nourrissent
vis-à-vis de ce pouvoir tant vis-à-vis
de ses orientations politiques que
vis-à-vis du style de présidence de
l'exécutif une forme de rejet de rejet
assez poussée donc je veux vraiment je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse être
confiant en revanche je note tout de
même que à l'aune de à la lumière de
cette popularité relativement élevée
alors encore une fois en fait les cotes
de popularité des manuels macron et de
et de nicolas sarkozy sont relativement
comparables cercle emmanuel macron se
situant tendance à peu près au niveau où
se situer nicolas sarkozy à une réserve
près nicolas sarkozy avait connu des
pics de popularité
supérieur et à françois hollande et
allemagne la con parce qu'il a
effectivement une sorte de fan club qui
a pu le monter très haut mais sinon
globalement les cotes de popularité sont
équivalentes
emmanuel macron est remontée à la faveur
de la crise duco vide une situation de
crise toujours ça génère comme une
poussée d'archimède une sorte de regain
de popularité dont françois hollande
lui-même avait bénéficié au moment de la
dame menace terroriste voilà alors
françois hollande n'était jamais
remonter aussi haut
il avait plafonné à 29 mai mais là à 41%
le socle reste fragile terre que la base
d' emmanuel macron et resserré et par
ailleurs c'est une base qui s'est
inversée au cours de son quinquennat
n'oublions jamais qu'il a été élu par
une france de centre gauche et qu'il est
aujourd'hui soutenue par une france de
centre-droit donc tout ça est quand même
assez fragile professeur sainte marie
est ce que cette analyse du sondage vous
paraît pertinent un homme paraît presque
trop beau c'est à dire alors des
tableaux j'ai encore des questions
j'avais quand même un peu vais réviser
en délire vous voir même si j'oublie mes
notes en fait mais c'est vrai les
sondage de l'ifop à hasnon élections et
dont je suis tombée sur l'or on a déjà
parlé de sarkozy de françois hollande
mais si on prend le risque un destin
imaginez-vous en avril 1980 était à 45
ans j'ai pas mes notes et 45 ou 46 %
donc et il a été battu pour ça on est à
peu près on est presque un an du premier
tour
donc ça c'est comparable ça prouve bien
que 41% n'est pas la garantie évidemment
qui venu le maquereau soirée par
ailleurs il ya une autre chose ça a été
souligné à l'instant
depuis le début du coc vide la cote
d'une exécutif de manuel macron plus
précisément c'est plutôt relevé en
janvier 2000
ben il était une situation très
compliquée parce qu'on était en pleine
réforme des retraites pourquoi est-ce qu
effectivement on a aujourd'hui 40 ou 42
% je crois de sympathisants de gauche
n'est ce pas 42 34 % des sympathisants
la france a soumis dans ce montage qui
sont satisfaits de l'action du président
de la république
alors moi je pense qu'il ya une raison
de plus on observe me semble observer
depuis quelques mois c'est qu'au fond
7 comment dirais-je la déception ou la
colère que j'ai beaucoup de
sympathisants de gauche qui pour
certains ont contribué à la victoire de
manuel macron aux pros second mais même
au premier tour c'était ça tenait au
fait que des réformes qui leur
paraissait comme anti sociale si j'ose
dire
la réforme des retraites etc et que par
ailleurs on a l'impression que ce pur
dans un esprit de gauche moi je comprend
une formulation a trait à gauche verte
est le président des riches quoi un peu
comme nicolas sarkozy à leurs yeux
sauf que là qu'est ce qui se passe
depuis un an les réformes qu'ils aient
polémiques ont été arrêtés au point que
ça leur est reproché par pas mal de
sympathisants de droite d'ailleurs blanc
relance tout quand même de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
voilà maintenant que les retraites les
réformes sont arrêtées là plus réforme
des retraites etc
pour l'instant ça on en voyait bien ça
repart mais pour l'instant c'est à
l'arrêt donc déjà ça fait quand même un
point d'accrochage qui est limité on
vivait dans un climat quand même tous
les week-ends depuis deux ans c'était
comme il ya des manifestations roi des
affrontements dans les rues des grandes
villes
c'est terminé et puis l'argent coule à
flots j'ai l'argent public
j'estime plus du keynésianisme à ce
niveau là ça devient carrément une
économie de guerre si vous voulez vous
avez les fonctionnaires qui votent
beaucoup à gauche n'ont pas perdu un
euro dans cette crise ils ont un
gouvernement qui permet les retraités
non plus ils ont permis ils ont un
gouvernement qui leur permet quand même
de maintenir donc ce niveau de revenus
alors que l'économie comme très
compliquée par l'emprunt pas pour eux de
leur point de vue ça leur va pas si mal
il ya des aides publiques dans tous les
sens y venir il ya le chômage partiel il
ya l'aide aux indépendants etc
donc c'est quasiment l'oeuvre d'un
gouvernement de gauche et en plus le
gouvernement agite sans cesse le
le comment dirais-je le spectre d'une
extrême droite pour ne pas dire du
fascisme au point que diabète board
justement j'ai eu avait enfin un tweet
récemment en tant que femme de gauche je
voterai pro macron face aux arènes et
c'est donc ça peut effectivement plaire
ça nous rappelle aussi autre chose quand
même que si pour la gauche elle-même
ça nous rappelle sa grande difficulté à
exister parce que non seulement une
partie de la gauche est déjà parent
était déjà allé chez emmanuel macron
mais qu'en plus la gauche ne s'est pas
finalement pour une bonne partie d'entre
elles si elle est pour ou contre le
pouvoir en place d'y aller dans
l'opposition dans la majorité
c'est une des raisons pour lequel une
candidature unique de gauche me paraît
assez utopique mais aussi nous faisons
nos enquêtes d'opinion mais ce ne sont
pas des sondages car c'est l'échantillon
représentatif des gens qui sont en train
de regarder sur twitter on vous pose la
question emmanuel macron peut-il gagner
la présidentielle
et c'est oui 54% donc c'est assez serré
et d'ailleurs sur youtube on vous a
aussi posé la question vous répondez à
linverse avec 66% de nom mais encore une
fois ce ne sont pas des sondages avec
toute la rigueur scientifique qui
accompagne ce genre d'étude gaye temps
sur youtube il à 90% de la population
contre lui abaga toi je suis pas sûr
parce que c'est parce que dit on a en
tout cas il a autant de chance de
repasser que moi de devenir roi
d'angleterre bon alors que le prince sur
youtube décidément c'est très royal ce
soir je dis oui il peut repasser
puisqu'il n'ya pas de solide opposition
en face
xavier sur lefigaro.fr aussi attention
si je me souviens des sondages dsk fut
président de la république et juppé lui
a succédé en 2010 cette réaction aux
cibles de kriss kross qui nous rappelle
que même s'il est populaire auprès des
jeunes c'est ce que vous disiez mathieu
ils votent très peu et puis patrick le
mieux serait qu'il ne se représente pas
ce recordwoman des jours de grève en
france
en écoutant jérôme sainte marie matthew
key je me disais en fait les français en
tout cas de gauche sont reconnaissants à
macro de ne plus être macron c'est ça
alors je pense que c'est assez compliqué
à analyser malgré tout est encore une
fois un les chiffres de son de ce
sondage questionne tout de même
oui pour l'interventionnisme public ça
c'est sûr alors je ne suis pas sûr que
ça le gratifie auprès de la gauche de
l'opinion de gauche malgré tout d'un
crédit si élevé que ça puisqu'on voit
bien qu'il s'agit quand même d'une
réponse à la crise et donc d'une mise en
pas entre parenthèses de réformes qui
ont vocation malgré tout à être remise
sur le sur l'établi et je pense encore
une fois à la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui vient d'être relancé alors
je jeûne look je ne comprends pas la
logique politique par exemple en fait de
cette réactivation de cette réforme
on a vendu cette réforme comme fondés
dans un contexte d'embellie cement
économique d'amélioration économique
devait réformer l'assurance chômage
à partir du moment où le chômage
descendait à 7% il était descendu à
quasiment 7% effectivement mais là on
voit bien que il remonte dans des
proportions considérables donc amputer
les chômeurs d'un certain nombre de
droits au moment où le chômage
c'est en ça paraît tout à fait être
votre tête qui disent qu'ils vont
réformer alors qu'ils leurs efforts
m'ont alors je sais peut-être de
l'afficheur encore une fois jean
j'entrevois assez peu de signaux dans la
politique menée à l'égard encore une
fois de l'électorat de gauche qui
avaient fait l'élection d' emmanuel
macron en 2017
non on a le sentiment que de façon
extrêmement cohérente et constante
il ya aucun reproche à lui faire là
dessus emmanuel macron gouverne au
centre droit et on comprend d'ailleurs
que dans la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle
il ya une forme d' asphyxie du camp de
la droite entre 1 emmanuel macron qui
gouverne au centre droit politique
européenne libérale assez classique et
sur les questions sociétales régaliennes
il fait du sécuritaire tranquille avec
darmanin qui incarne qui fait le job
donc on voit bien que il est il est dans
son couloir de centre-droit et on va on
a par ailleurs une marine le pen qui de
façon très accéléré depuis quelques
semaines se recentre il ya une
dédiabolisation qui est en fait un
recentrage on l'a vu dans son débat avec
darmanin on le voit dans les prises dans
les prises de positions qui sont les
siennes aujourd'hui sur l'europe sur
l'euro
sur la dette on voit bien que elle
cherche à ne plus effrayer l'électorat
de droite traditionnelle et on se dit
que dans cette configuration là un
candidat des républicains est
globalement pris en sandwich et on ne
mesure pas quel est son espace politique
en revanche à gauche je ne comprend pas
si je comprends que la gauche est très
affaiblie par le quinquennat de françois
hollande
au point que françois hollande lui-même
avaient été impuissantes et au point que
manuel valls qui devait le remplacer
n'avait même pas pu se présenter avait
été battu à la primaire et au point que
benoît hamon sorti vainqueur de la
primaire a fini totalement à poil avec 6
ou 7% de voix
voilà donc la gauche a été tellement
faible en 2010 est qu'elle le reste
encore quatre ans après mais il y a un
espace politique à gauche me semble-t-il
qui est lui totalement totalement laissé
libre par emmanuel macron et par sa
politique et par ailleurs je note en
fait que dans l'enquêté sur les
fractures françaises
on observe que à gauche à gauche je ne
sais pas si si l'union est souhaitable
et si elle permettrait pour de vrai une
victoire je n'y crois pas trop en termes
d' analyse politique je note néanmoins
qu'elle est souhaitée par tous les
sympathisants de gauche tous y compris
les sympathisants de la france insoumise
et c'est même une surprise pour moi
les deux tiers des électeurs écolos les
trois quarts des électeurs socialistes
et 81% des sympathisants de la france
insoumise souhaiterait une candidature
unitaire et on note par ailleurs que sur
l'ensemble des grands sujets à
l'exception sans doute du libéralisme
économique
les trois composantes de la gauche se
retrouvent sur l'essentiel il ya plus 80
candidats maintenant en tout état de
cause on n'y est pas je crois que ces
chiffres nous montrent surtout que
chaque électorat pense que ce sera son
propre champions qui sera à la tête de
cette union rejet chez les socialistes
et au delà des différences assez
importante encore une fois au sein de
saturer de la gauche mais c'est un autre
problème
provenir emmanuel macron à votre
question moi je crois pas du tout qu
emmanuel macron mais c'est un débat
qu'on a quasiment toutes les quinze
jours ensemble ils manient le maquereau
soit au centre-droit emmanuel macron et
la synthèse de la gauche de la droite de
gouvernement
est ce que par rapport en matière de sa
politique sociale est ce qu'il est
vraiment différent de la politique de
manuel valls
sincèrement travail font tous cas je ne
vois pas les niches fiscales
notez qu'en ans de politique fiscale je
les options je ne vois plus clair que
par ailleurs les réformes qui sont
menées sur les réformes qui pour
l'essentiel ne sont ne naissent pas dans
l'imaginaire des politiques nationaux
mais sur l'application de dire et de
consignes européenne notamment en
contrepartie des prêts qui sont
consentis et de tolérance qui sont
faites à l'avs
ans donc je crois en acquérir deux
simples de symbolique politique que ce
soit la politique fiscale ou encore une
fois les quelques réformes symboliques
qui ont été faites qui sont 1 la réforme
des régimes spéciaux de retraite qu'un
scal seul à droite attendait depuis très
longtemps ou encore une fois la réforme
de l'assurance chômage aussi faisant
passer les chômeurs pour des assistés
qui veulent my
on voit bien qu'on émette une
philosophie qui n'est pas celle de la
méchante du chômage en terme d'opinion
c'est malheureusement pour eux les
chômeurs sont un peu seuls au monde
parce que les français sont toujours
favorables à la réduction de l'indemnité
chômage parce que il ya cette idée que
beaucoup d'un jeu d'horreur le sont un
peu chaud mais elle va être forte et
stable d'un point de vue économique et
social
c'est une réalité d'opinion et c'est
peut-être pour ça que cette réforme est
maintenu en tout cas dans son nom
fichage étonnamment les relancer je
donne le dernier mois nos internautes à
babineau qu'on salue oui on confond
popularité et intentions de vote
en temps de crise donc a priori ça
devrait pas être la même chose selon lui
s'il est réélu nous dit lorenzo c'est
que l'abstention et s'il est réélu et
que l'abstention est énorme ça ne voudra
rien dire il n'aura plus aucune
légitimité
et puis je vous propose encore d'écouter
jo sur youtube on peut penser qu'il
repassera tout en espérant le contraire
baisser votre droit et puis patrick sur
twitter le mieux serait qu'il ne se
représente pas ce record dman des jours
de grève en france et nous terminons sur
cette note même si elle est un peu
sombre détiennent sur lefigaro.fr les
pros et les antis macron n'ont jamais
été aussi fort j'ai peur qu'on se
divisent qu'on se dirige pardon vers un
scénario à l'américaine
une france ultra divisé bien qu'il reste
un peu plus d'un an maintenant pour le
savoir merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et à
demain pour un nouveau rendez vous
[Musique]